the titans
and this one
it's important that we get the phrasing
right yeah they have not cut vic beasley
yet right they're going to cut vic
beasley today and there's an important
reason why they're going to cut vic
beasley today if they cut him yesterday
he becomes a free agent and he can
collect the balance of his three and a
half million dollar salary from the
titans his termination pay go play for
someone else and double dip
and he already got a six million dollar
signing bonus right from the titans now
he may have had to give some of it back
because he was a awol for a couple of
weeks at the start of camp
but
if they
cut him today which is what they're
going to do
that salary passes through waivers the
contract goes through waivers that's one
of the key differences post trade
deadline all players regardless of
experience now must go through waivers
and maybe someone will look at the
balance of his salary 1.85 million over
the next nine weeks
and say
we'll take that we'll pick up that
contract and if they do the titans avoid
paying the guy another 1.85 million
that's why he wasn't released yesterday
that's why the report was he will be
released today the titans are hoping
that maybe the seahawks right right
right who who could use help at the pass
rush or any other team that's looking
for a pass rusher will say we'll we'll
spend the 1.85 million to get dibs on
this guy otherwise we have to go sign
him as a free agent yeah i mean it makes
total sense there from what tennessee
did there's there's definitely going to
be some teams that i think are going to
do their due diligence on vic beasley
you know vic beasley though the big
thing is it's just going to be about him
the human being is he invested into
football right now you know that's those
are things that i know about the
situation it's more of a personal thing
that held vic beasley out through
training camp when he was a no-show and
type those type of things he's trying to
figure out where he wanted to go in his
life and that's perfectly fine i'm not
trying to you know judge or anything
like that but i think again for teams to
claim him on waivers that'll be the big
part of this story i mean he did nothing
for the tennessee titans that's not
going to make teams feel very warm and
cozy about oh let's give the guy 1.8
million the guy who didn't show up at
training camp and then you know they
tried to slowly infuse him into the
lineup and it didn't really take and he
didn't really do anything and then it
became basically we don't even play him
here at the very end and this is a team
two
that is pass rush deficient so i think
that will scare teams away too
ultimately because they're gonna go wait
the titans one of the worst things on
their team is their pass rush and
they're letting go of a pass rusher so
there must be a real issue there and
we'll see where it goes but yeah that's
always been my understanding vic beasley
you know just going through some things
there figuring out what direction he
wants to go in his life and we'll see
what happens but i don't think anybody
will claim him on waivers just because
of the things i just stated there
25 of the defensive snaps he
participated in zero sacks zero
quarterback hits so something's not
right there and look everyone has issues
that come up from time to time and we
wish vic beasley the best in navigating
them it's just unfortunate that
the titans gave him a one-year 9.5
million dollar contract with a signing
bonus of six million dollars right
and
you know you're either all in or you're
not and i know things can happen after
you sign that contract that make you not
all in and you're trying to navigate
life and of all years this is the
toughest year to navigate the various
challenges it's just unfortunate for
everyone involved and the titans decided
that they want to try to cut the losses
stop the financial bleeding and instead
of cutting him yesterday and walking
right into that 1.85 million dollar rake
they are waiting to today and hoping
that someone will say
it's worth the gamble
in the event that we can
can get this guy in the right mindset
for the rest of the season we can give
him a place where he feels like his
concern and again i'm not saying the
titans were not
sufficiently sensitive to his concerns
but you know anytime there's a guy who
fails in one city for whatever reason
chris you know this yeah there's another
coach out there who thinks i can say the
right thing i can do the right thing i
can fix it right i can help this guy fix
it right and in return i'm going to get
a great player and that's exactly the
attitude that pete carroll would have
yeah you're right about that he you're
right you know we'll get him up here
he'll he'll see this place he'll feel
our energy
he'll he'll want to play he'll want to
do it certainly you're right i mean hey
listen look tampa they're doing the same
thing i mean it's antonio brown oh yeah
i think we can fix them we got tom brady
he'll help we got some coaches from the
pittsburgh roster that were there when
he was there that'll help so yes that
same idea i'm sure they're gonna
seriously think about that because i
mean again we know seattle is obviously
in the super bowl window and it's not
that their defense has to make some
remarkable jump it just has to go from
like let's get into the 20s the low 20s
and total defense instead of 31 or 32
and it'll make their team so much better
uh so we'll see we'll see where that
goes big beazley though you know that's
risky i think for those teams and
they're gonna have to do their due
diligence on you know how invested he is
in the game right now
yeah and look the financially safer
course is to let him become a free agent
right
and and sign into a contract that
protects you against him not working out
if you want to cut him at some point
whatever the case may be you're not on
the hook for 1.85 million the risk
though is if you let him pass through
waivers
he may not want to come play for you and
maybe we're at the point where
he should just pick his next team it
shouldn't be right guy gets snatched on
waivers amid a pandemic and has to move
to seattle unless that's where he wants
to go if it's where he wants to go
that's a different issue but
complicated situation for the titans and
for vic beasley and they've found a way
out of it now
what in the world is wrong with the
titans pass rush they have jadav and
clown and they have jeffrey simmons
why can't they get to the quarterback
especially when they played a team last
weekend that had 80 percent turnover and
it's starting offensive line because of
injury yeah no i mean that was one of
the surprise you know shocks of the
weekend first off i mean i watched this
film yesterday i did i mean you know the
bengals offense a line they did a pretty
good job now the real story of the day
though
is
one zach taylor had a very good game
plan he wasn't gonna let joe burrow sit
back there all day long and you know
throw the ball deep down the field and
plays like that where he's gonna take a
long time to develop and let the pass
rush get off they stayed very consistent
with short passing game get the ball out
of your hands the pass rush is getting
better there in tennessee now between
zach taylor and then the main thing
which is joe burrow is freaking awesome
he's slippery as hell he breaks and gets
away from more damn sacks than just
about anybody in football that way and
there was a lot of projects for him yeah
go ahead yeah this is very important far
more important than any analysis you're
about to provide right i am directing
you to come up with a joe burrows song
and i think slippery as hell needs to be
part of it okay okay i'll try to work
that in but you know that was really i
was encouraged actually by the titans
pass rush in the game overall on plays
when he had to wait for something to
develop hey clowney got close a lot
simmons is really a good player and they
tried their best to double team him and
do that but clowney's best thing is not
necessarily a top-tier pass rusher he's
a top-tier disrupter that's really what
he is he's not the kind of guy that's
going to bend around the corner like von
miller gets sack after sack he can't
even really do that because of the micro
fracture knee he has that's one of the
issues why teams don't want to pay him
long-term contracts so from that aspect
he can collapse the pocket and cause
disruption he's not a sack master harold
landry on the other side is a real good
football player you know he does
everything well but he's just not a
superstar pass rusher that way either
and yeah they're still trying to find
their way there and they need clowney to
stay healthy for consecutive weeks
that'll be the other thing too it can't
be oh jiudevian played a good game now
his knee and he's bothered for two weeks
and yeah he played but he played it like
70 and oh now he's back to awesome and
then oh man he's down to 70 again that's
the issue too sometimes with tennessee
and uh yeah we'll see where it goes but
it's certainly an issue on their
football team
and it's unfortunate for clowning he's
never gotten that truly gigantic
contract deserved he was drafted three
years after the rookie wage scale was
put in place and he seems destined to be
a one year at a time barnstormer from
team to team city to city somebody who
gets infatuated by what he can do when
healthy and is willing to tolerate the
moments when he isn't
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports